-Little Big Town! I'm so happy you're here!
-Hey, Jimmy. -Congrats on the new album.
Thanks for doing "Rich Man" tonight.
I gotta say my favorite song on the album is "Hell Yeah."
You guys excited to be here?
-♪ Hell yeah ♪
-Oh-ho! That's what I'm talking about.
Let me know if I can get you guys anything.
-♪ Hell yeah ♪
-Maybe some chips?
-Ooh, my fantasy-football team's looking good this week!
-♪ Hell yeah ♪
-Ooh, today's crossword puzzle's tough.
Do you guys know the opposite of "heaven"...
and a four-letter word that means yes?
-♪ Hell yeah ♪
-That's it! Perfect!
Hey, you guys wanna hang out after the show?
-Oh... -Um, I gotta call my mom.
-Yeah, man, I-I got a thing... -I made a dinner reservation.
-Cool. Alright. Thanks.
I think -- I'll take that as a "hell yeah."
-Hell yeah.